Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is
Not Allowed To Do At The Foundation:
Attempting to disprove 343, to 343. It’s a
horrible idea. Agents are still studying the
resulting paperweight, supposedly so heavy
that 343 should not be able to lift it.
For context, while debate around the truth
of this matter rages among Foundation staff
and in our comment sections, SCP-343
is a reality-warping anomaly that
refers to itself as God - believed to be
omnipresent, omniscient, and omnipotent.
A classic thought experiment on the possibility
of this is whether God is capable of creating
an object they themself couldn’t lift -
resulting in a paradox. Or, in this case,
an astronomically heavy paperweight that
the SCP Foundation now needs to deal with.
Thanks, Jack.